so hello everybody my name is hung and
i'm the founder and the product lead
here at y42
first of all you know i tend to move a
lot of my hands and i'm not used to
holding a microphone like this so in
case yeah i'm dropping my hand like this
just tell me please okay thank you
all right let's get started first of all
i hope you don't get any motion sickness
from looking at this gif
um in case yes i'm trying to skip over
it very fast but
today i'm very excited to announce a
major yeah we call it data revolution
using git as a nosql database
and
this is a very
yeah
that's an interesting talk for me we
have worked tirelessly for the past six
months to create a new product with y42
and this is actually the very first time
that we show it to the world um here at
data council and
it's my first time at data council thank
you so much
it's my first time at data council and
obviously i've been attending a lot of
talks before
and what i realized during these talks
is that the folks here are very
sophisticated right we have a very high
level of technical sophistication
and we tend to forget that we're in this
engineering and vc bubble
and the majority of companies out there
they're not able to stitch together five
different tools from the modern data
stack and really maintain and run it so
we don't like we shouldn't forget this
is a bubble that we're in here and this
is why
y42 has made it a mission to enable
not working okay to enable everyone to
work with their data effectively um and
keeping that in mind we were facing you
know a lot of challenges we had to
include the business user within the
data uh value process
we have to make it as frictionless as
possible so data engineers and business
user can work together
and this is why y42 yeah started two
years ago
before jumping into the new data
revolution the
v2 that we're about to present i would
like to show you how the v1 actually
looks like first
can you jump to the next
sorry oh
whether you are marketing at a data
engineer or manager in the next minutes
i will show you how you can set up a
scalable data pipeline from connecting
your data sources over modelling your
data to automating your dashboards y42
removes the complexity of stitching
together data infrastructure
hey my name is rebecca and i have helped
leading startups and e-commerce
companies to set up their data stack in
no time let's get started
on the left you can see the different
modules that you need to run a fully
automated scalable data platform
integrate model visualize and
orchestrate
right now we are within visualize now
assume we are an e-commerce looking to
track our ad spend by channel that month
updating near real time
i will show you how to get this
dashboard up and running from start to
finish
first things first let's go to integrate
to connect our data sources
you can select one of over 100
plug-and-play connectors for instance
here we have connected facebook ads
where you can pick what tables and
columns you want to automatically load
let's go with ads insights click on
import and boom we are done
all of the raw data has been loaded and
stored on your data warehouse for you
see here all your data is there
y42 helps you to set up or connect to an
existing data warehouse it takes care of
your configurations and maintenance for
this product here i've gone ahead and
connected both google ads and facebook
ads data
the next step is to go to web32 modeling
to transform and merge the two data
sources
you have the choice between no code
modeling or sql based modeling for now
let's jump into the node production
what you can see here on the left are
modeling nodes with then you can do
everything that's possible in sql
for our use case we are pulling in data
from google ads we then pass the date
into a proper format in the next steps
you will see that google ads ad spend
data is provided in a weird unit
therefore we will have to divide the ad
spent by 1 million which you can easily
do using our functions node that works
just like excel functions
we do the respective cleaning for
facebook ads and then union the data to
create the final output table
that's it we have done with the modeling
step
and just to show you you could easily
pick up on the output table we just
created and use sql to further transform
your data
i will create a secret model here and
now i can write some standard sql to
further aggregate the data
alright now that we have merged the
google and the facebook ads data simply
go to visualize select the output table
you want and build your dashboard
at this point you've got your dashboard
however you could even go one step
beyond using our automate feature to
send your data back to your marketing or
crm tools like you see here
with all these amazing pipelines and
automations it's easy to lose track over
everything
exactly for that reason we have built
our data lineage where you can
effortless trace where your data comes
from and how everything is connected
but now the final step after integrating
and modeling your data is to automate
the whole pipeline
via orchestrate you can easily have y42
auto-generate the entire path of how
your data flows and then you can set a
near real-time update schedule no need
to write any script and waste precious
engineering time
et voila this is truly the beauty of y42
it didn't even take us five minutes to
set up a fully automated data platform
and it didn't even have to touch a
single line of code
okay awesome so that was um the version
1.0
which is roughly nine months old right
now and to really sum it up quickly
what's the platform about as you can see
y 42 covers the entire data pipeline
end-to-end from integration to
modeling orchestration visualization
export etc and it all works on top of a
data warehouse such as bigquery or
snowflake
so with this version you know we had a
reasonably uh great amount of adoption
the nps was was quite high with 75. so
we were able to you know cover a lot of
use cases especially for
non-technical users but we also realized
over time that we ran into quite a lot
of issues
first of all
these kind of tools right
at some point you grow to a point where
you want to include engineers within
your team
and this is not very user friendly
if you have to do everything no code i'm
an engineer myself so i would like to
have everything with code as much as
possible also next
if you take a look at our
architecture
each of this tool would be a
microservice that is saving the data
within a relational database
in this case everything was a mysql
database so as you can imagine we ran
into problems like how do we template
things right how do we roll back certain
stuff it's very difficult using a mysql
database um how do we collaborate
because people keep overwriting each
other
so as of this point you know everybody
in this room would think of well let's
just use git right that's very very
obvious
and this is also exactly what we did
we just abandoned all our mysql
databases of each of these tools and
just put yeah save everything in git
save every settings in git but at the
same time we're saving every status and
basically every information possible
within git making it truly a nosql
database so if you want to use y42 as of
right now you would need to provide us
one data warehouse such as google
bigquery or snowflake and you would need
to provide us one
git repo hosted on github or you know
gitlab and
we with that approach we are also able
to really include every tool of the
modern data stack running it under the
hood so for example we have 50
of our own integrations built we can
include error byte within the process we
can you know connect with 5tran an
airflow run can trigger our orchestrator
and our orchestrator can trigger an
airflow run
we can connect with any visualization
tool out there because the tables are
inside the data warehouse we can run dbt
under the hood and so on so i would like
to
really show you in the next step v2 for
the very first time and how it actually
uses git as a nosql database in the
background
hey everybody i'm incredibly excited to
welcome you to the new y-42 app um for
today's demo i've already set up an
account called data council and in order
for wi-fi to work we would need to
provide
a cloud storage such as you know google
cloud storage s3 a data warehouse such
as bigquery or snowflake and most
importantly a git repo hosted on github
or gitlab
i really didn't want to bore you too
much today with the setup so i've
already connected the data console
account with
a bigquery a google cloud storage and a
github repo
so
the important part for this demo is
really the git repo
y42 data council db
this is the one that is connected to
this account and i've already opened
within github
so
you have to really remember we save
every file um yeah and basically
everything within git now as a nosql
database replacement so you can also see
that the folder structure resembles the
tools that we also offer within y42 such
as integrations model orchestration and
so on now let's see the very first
innovation that we made
when we refresh the app
what's happening under the hood is we
clone the remote repository you know we
do it fetch we pull and we started
within the browser file system inside
indexeddb
so under the hood we developed our own
git client for the browser using wasn't
git which is a web assembly compiled
version of lookbook 2.
so
let's set up a completely new
integration from scratch and you will
understand everything much better
immediately so let's go but before doing
that
let's actually create a new branch first
let's create a branch called git data
console
of the master branch
now
let's create a new google ads
integration
call data council
google ads
i will just show you the whole process
real quick and explain you afterwards
what's happening okay
i mean first step is very clear let's
authorize ourselves with google ads
first using
oauth
in the next step we're loading all the
available accounts i have connected with
my google account that i just authorized
myself with
let's start importing data from march
last year
and both of the google ads account
that i have available
and the schemas have loaded successfully
with that we have every possible table
and columns available that we can import
now
from the google ads integration
let me just go ahead and import
everything every possible column from
the
ad groups table
so an import job has been triggered
and we can see all the log streaming in
right now
great
it's finished
the data has imported successfully
let's take a look at the data that we're
actually getting from this import job
and you can see that we imported a total
24 rows for the google ads table
this is the actual representation of the
data that has been created inside
bigquery immediately so this job that
ran created this table that you see
right here
let's play a bit of detective and trace
back the different git commits and see
what really happened under the hood
so first of all
i created a new google ads integration
and this with the name data council
google ads you can see it right here i'm
already in the right branch called git
data council and we created this data
council google ads brand and these are
the metadata and the settings json that
i just talked about
right in the subsequent step you would
see that the back end would commit
a secret um yeah an encrypted secret
which is the token that we just
authorize ourselves with with google um
yeah it gets encrypted and the backend
commits it the back end and the wi-fi to
back and also commits the accounts and
commits the different schema so the
schema again this is the collection of
tables and columns that we can actually
import
and let's take a look at it again
so we go to this folder and everything
within this dot y42 folder has been
committed by the y42 back end
really making it
a nosql database replacement
let's continue our
journey to trace back what happens
after we created the table and committed
it we also triggered a job and let's
take a look at the history just from the
jobs file
first of all we see that the first time
we triggered it the y-42 back-end
commits a file that basically says the
request
that we just created
we wanted to import these columns and
from this table
and the status starts off with pending
so in a couple of steps we add more
information to it until finally it
switches from pending to ready and
we also know exactly what columns has
been imported by now and what type it is
and most importantly
this job created a table inside the data
warehouse that i already showed you this
is basically the link um to this table
inside the digital house
and yeah you could you know every file
within y42 has
the full history and you can maybe
revert the file if you need it to be um
or you can trace back what really
happened under the hoods
and the beauty of all of this now we
created this integration on the git data
council branch we ran a job that you
know might take a couple of minutes
sometimes a couple of hours and all of
this is not available on the master
branch yet so going back um
going back right here this data account
to google ads integration is not a
master yet let's just quickly switch and
really make sure right now what we're
going to do is we will merge this git
data council branch and we'll see all
the commits will merge it into
master refreshing
reloading
cloning the entire app again
and just within a couple of minutes you
see data council google ads integration
is now fully available on the master
branch after the merge that we did and
the table we can immediately consume it
because it has been pre-built before on
the other account and i really hope by
now you understand why we are merging
files while we're immersing the job
statuses
within git as well using it as a nosql
database
cool that was
a quick demo of how the new platform
looks like
i would love to have shown you that live
here but i think it would have been
logistically a bit difficult to set up
my laptop all the way um to the back so
sorry for showing you a bunch of videos
today
nevertheless to really uh summarize what
just happened right first of all we
built our own git client
in the browser using web assembly to
compile libgit2 and we're the very first
company that has ever done that and this
is highly experimental because we're
cloning a big repository where
everything gets safe in there right the
jobs get safe in there the accounts the
schema the settings so if you take a
look at this visualization at this slide
here i mean first of all the first thing
that people would think of using git is
obviously just to save the settings the
settings would for example be
like for the integrations i want to save
the which columns like id and revenue
and the tables called the orders table
right and then every time the y42 back
end or the y42 bot would take these
settings and actually run a job so it
runs a job and it creates a table inside
the data warehouse so there's a linear
um like they're directly
connected the job with the table inside
the data warehouse and
we were fighting a lot uh for a long
time where to save this job should we
save it in a you know a different
database or should we save it directly
within git and
obviously as you can see it in the demo
we decided to stick and really save
everything within git so when you run a
job and then you merge it from one
branch to another it would be available
immediately
right but the power of git just doesn't
stop there let's take a look at the next
demo
now comes my absolutely favorite part
the power of git and a file system under
the hood is really limitless let me
showcase you a couple of examples by
first renaming these google ads
integration from main adwords to data
council integration
you can see that
we made this local change now
and i haven't committed these changes
yet
now i can use the built-in y42 terminal
to run any git commands under the hood
so with git status you would see we're
on range master and we just change one
file the metadata json file by just
renaming it as you see before
um we can do
git stash now so it would basically yeah
we stash the changes and it gets renamed
back to main adwords um but i kind of
like this data council integration name
so i will restore it
and in a second you see it's back here
so you see there's the perfect interplay
between the built-in terminal between
code and between the ui
now the power doesn't stop there
we build our own y42 cli that can be
used locally in your ide but in this
case in the file system of the browser
so let's check it out
uh we can generate uh staff
so what is staff well let's take a look
at the help center we can generate for
example an integration so let's go ahead
and actually do that
i know i need a name property
i will call it new my sequel
of type mysql
and voila
that's all i need using the y42cli
to generate a new mysql integration
but
the power doesn't stop just within the
file system the cli
but we have all the apis available as
well you can create new integrations uh
programmatically you can authorize
yourself with that even using oauth you
can trigger a new import job
and yeah let's just do that right now so
i've already put in the right space id
which is the github repo this y 42 data
council repo here
i'm on branch master right now
and um company id 141 is the data
council company
and i want to trigger a new integrations
job for the main adwords that we yeah uh
just showcase so let's go back here uh
go back to the main adwords integration
let me actually you know
discard this change i want to yeah have
it back to main edwards so you see here
in a second we will trigger a job using
the api
and let's just execute it
let's see it was successful so let's go
back here
i'm not doing anything the ui will react
to it yeah automatically so we see we
just trigger a new
integration job in here the locks are
coming in right now
and this was just really beautiful
right if you you see what just happened
is we use the cli we use the y42 api
and what i just showed you really allows
companies like marketing agencies bi
agencies private equity firm and any
companies with multiple brands spin up
their entire data pipeline
programmatically with just one click
i have another easter egg for you
with everything as code
there's some really cool stuff we can
yeah make happen
so for that
i've prepared for today a dashboard
and
yeah it's just our dashboarding system
you know nothing really fancy and the
first thing i want to show you is
everything is code now and i just move
the position of this widget and clearly
you can see the x and the y axis moving
i don't want it to be at this position
so i'm going to discard these the
changes for now
um
the interesting part is when we create a
new let's just create a new tab called
tab two
and
i'm gonna create a new widget now
and i'm very excited to
really show you guys what's happening
next um i'm already uh connected to a
data source table um in this case a
model and
i'm gonna put the
order created here in here and i'm going
to put the total price in here
i also know i want to change it to year
and month
and i also want the total discount
next to it
and
i want to make the total price for now
an area chart
maybe at an access point so when we
hover over yeah we can see
cool looks fancy
very fancy very nice
we have the chart here let me complete
the changes
great
in the meanwhile let's jump straight to
our ide here to the visualization folder
let's do fetch
and pull
now you will see that
we created the tab 2 as you remember so
within this tab 2
we created the widget with this id here
let me quickly look it up
this is the
widget
let's look it up the widget
there it is
so this is the widget we just created
from the ui
and
under the hood
we're using e-charts as a charting
engine
made by baidu it's open source extremely
beautiful and powerful
but it has literally thousands of
properties to bind that there's no way
for us to build it all in ui
so
since we have everything as code we
could take all of these properties in
here and
just in check them
right within the ide you have the json
schema up here so everything you know
gets autofocus
how about you know i'm changing
the x-axis
and i move it to
position top
i also want
let's do the legend
and
change the icon to
triangle
cool
and
now let's see all the changes that we
made all right these are the extra
properties
let's merge
widget changes
um i'm doing it with github desktop so
you guys can really see all the very
visual changes that we've been doing in
our ide
and now let's go back here let's fetch
and pull all the changes
and see immediately
how
the legend changes uh yeah to a triangle
and the x-axis
moves to position top
beautiful
cool
yeah i hope you understand what just
happened there under the hood so
we really enable
the whole platform becomes everything is
code at the end of the day we can use
the ui to create all of these settings
the backend commits all the files as
well you can merge that between branches
engineers can really use this platform
to code in the background so let me just
show you the last video and then i will
not bore you anymore it's just as a
full-fledged data pipeline tool we allow
the users to transform the data using
our ui model or sql model
i'm not going to go into too much detail
but to really quickly showcase you
at the end of the day we offer a
non-technical user
the opportunity to really transform the
data using our tree or workflow builder
that is our own json format and whenever
an import job runs
we take this json and we transform it
into highly efficient sql queries to
create and update a table within the
data warehouse
and we're pretty confident that we cover
99 of all the use cases with sql
directly with our ui model
but for those who really want to use sql
directly under the hood
we also offer sql model so in this case
this is a very native sql model
integration
you can write sql straight from
the browser ide or straight within your
local ide so this is the repo i already
cloned it within the id here ide here
before
we are also halfway through integrating
perfectly with dbt so instead of writing
you know a native sql you can just write
ginger and that also just compiles down
to sql whenever a job runs similar to
our ui model
what is more let's say attractive of y42
is the orchestration layer and it is
basically yeah like airflow so the user
can build um directed acyclic graphs
basically when this import job finishes
trigger the next import job you know
trigger maybe a weapon
trigger maybe an export or another
airflow run and airflow can trigger us
just perfectly fine
because yeah everything is
programmatically
available within y42 so you can you know
integrate it with airflow execute
another airflow run or prefect or
whatever tool you want
and last but not least
the most powerful feature of y42 is uh
within the all-in-one platform we own
all the metadata
so all the way from dashboard you know
to data transformation to
integration we know exactly where your
data are coming from what happened to
them along the way so for example this
dashboard uses these five widgets um and
this one widget comes from the daily ad
spend and the daily ad spend comes from
you know these two integrations right
here and
we
know just every time you know when an
error happens why does it happen we can
trace it back so
you have the highest level of
observability and debuggability possible
within the y42 platform
cool so
let's come to the challenges that we are
actually facing when running git as a
database and the first question
we would always get asked is hey
what are the their performance issues
right and this is also the first
question um
i don't think i can go back with the
slide right is that possible let me test
it
okay sorry um so let's talk about the
performance issue for a bit and i just
want to keep it as raw as possible so we
had a lot of internal discussions and
i'm just going to smash in you know a
couple of um yeah our slack chats in
here and i think the most relevant one
is the one with chris
saying
hey he
for your information i just tested it a
bit locally with a local git repo i had
11 000 files somewhat similar to the run
files with four commits each the repo
ended up with a 12 gigabyte data on the
git folder a shallow clone depth equals
1 was 50 megabyte roughly the size of
the files git gc takes a while one to
two minutes but brings down the overall
repo size to 94 megabyte while
maintaining the full history and get gc
aggressive is a bit slower but brings
down the size to 75 megabyte so overall
the history is big but we can shrink it
back down to
0.0007 percent of its size with a single
command and
there's a lot of implications we tested
um the same data pipeline that one of
our biggest enterprise clients would run
and using git when you keep cleaning up
the jobs that are being saved in git
let's say every three months such as
century right and you run a lot of
optimization commands and garbage
collectors
then you can really get the file size
down very efficiently also
on the picture on the top this is the
the front and side of things git clone
takes only 1.15 megabyte and these are
608 integrations 216 models and 178
orchestration with 48 visualizations um
so i think we are pretty much covered on
that size we are also building our own
git server and we keep optimizing there
um yeah and
we can update you next year's at data
council if we really run
this new product on a very big
enterprise
whether we still encounter any
performance problems or not
yeah
i mean to really
let's go back to another problem that we
have i'm trying to
so access control that's also a major
problem that we encounter and we haven't
solved it perfectly yet because what
we're using right now is we don't have
any ids anymore but we're using the file
path as ids because they are yeah
usually unique you cannot create the
same file twice within the same folder
so
that makes it very difficult because
then everybody that has you know that is
cloning this repo
in the within the front and can
basically change the name of the folder
and then grant him or herself access um
to a data table under the hood and this
is something where you know we were
fighting uh
this problem is it's a major problem we
haven't solved it perfectly yet but what
we
can do and what we're in the process of
implementing is once again our own git
server so every time somebody would push
um to that
yeah to that repo we know that and what
we will do is we just um gonna implement
a hook and see whether this user is
allowed to actually make this push and
like for example change the folder
um yeah last but not least as i've
already said it is highly experimental
um actually implementing git in the
browser so um
check out wasn't git that's a library we
are one of the main contributors now
to this one and i think if you applied
even outside of the data space and this
is a very rewarding approach for any
other industry running git in the
browser as we do
and yeah so to really summarize what is
y42 what is the new version of y42 what
is our value proposition well we use git
as a database that powers an all in one
data workspace and really the emphasis
is here in all in one data workspace and
we remove all the tooling friction
no more stitching together or switching
between five different tools when you
set up the modern data stack you can
integrate with any tools of the modern
data stack that you will need to
you have you know every orchestration on
observability layer across the pipeline
from integration to visualization and
obviously also data lineage and catalog
very powerful if you have all your data
within one place
next it's also openly programmable you
know you can build it using the y42u
cli you can use the api or you can use
the ui
and it makes templating extremely easy
to use so we can pre-build end-to-end
templates such as
you know a dtc company that wants to or
let's say a b2b sas that would usually
use chart mogul right now we could
pre-build all of that dashboard and
provide them
yeah right off the box
and we can spin up entire pipelines with
just one single click for you know
aggregated use cases that have multiple
brands that they need to manage
and last but not least and this is also
one of the most important points why
we're building y-42
we believe in a world where data
engineers data analysts and business
users work seamlessly together because
we really think that's the time when
organization really transcend uh
collaborating between people
that have yeah different point of views
so
with the y42 platform analysts and
engineers can collaborate seamlessly
using code or no code low code
everything version control auditing
backup replication powered as git yeah
makes it very collaborative instead of
before where everybody would override
each other
and yeah we added a lot of you know
features like figma was bringing to the
web such as commenting canvas and
basically every collaboration yeah
possibilities you have right now with
the modern cloud area era
and so yeah i um inviting you to be part
of this uh
revolution of this app we are launching
it in six weeks from now um you can
check it out on our website uh
threeletter.comdomainy42.com
and we yeah i'm gonna have my
um
i think office hour right after that so
please feel free to come ask me any
questions um also we're gonna have our
workshop um in a couple of hours from
now so there you can you know lay your
hand on the new app
and yeah test it out thank you so much
all right give it up for hong from y42
[Applause]